and we're gonna be talking about Sonic
the Hedgehog spoilers
spoiler alert boiler alert we're
spoiling it was spoiling at all we're
gonna spoil it all cuz we're also gonna
be talking about birds of prey yes again
yeah but you're gonna love it you guys
I'm sure look at everybody's seen the
title and they're like ooh that that
plays right to my confirmation bias I'm
so into this yeah so before we get
started if you want to get the super
chat
we got three segments we're not gonna go
too long so I'm on the verge of passing
out but we're gonna go for it anyway so
get your super chance we'll answer them
in between segments join if you want to
get the full podcast by clicking the
join button just below this video or
going to youtube.com slash Tim cast IRL
slash join and I don't know let's just
uh let's just let's just jump right into
it
I saw a random chat that someone said
don't forget to hit record
but thank you random person so earlier
today we had to get some stuff for the
new game when we're setting up and I we
went really long last night so I'm super
tired I wake up today I'm like gotta
work got very little sleep go to Adams
room knock on the door and I'm like hey
you want to go to Blockbuster after I
finish and I was like but here's what I
was thinking I was like blockbuster is
two words of the be best to buy same
colors yes I just man I need sleep I was
dude you need sleep
ya know it's funny enough you don't look
like you need sleep I don't you sound
you you did ask me to go to Blockbuster
and then I'm just like oh she's funny
enough that's actually the first place I
ever worked at I still have the shirt
and my nametag that could be a Halloween
costume one day
alright let's uh let's talk about sign
of the Hedgehog that movie was awesome
it was awesome I enjoyed it I laughed a
lot right right off the bat I give it a
seven a little bit maybe seven point
five out of ten that's exactly what I
would get it it wasn't seven point five
it's not Lord of the Rings no it's as
much as but it sounded that job I think
yeah the the stakes were a little low
but didn't matter it was about Sonic
mm-hm it was funny it was good I giggled
a lot I laughed out loud actually and
one of it not many movies can make me
laugh out loud so there's going to be
spoilers you know just just so you know
the spoilers but here's the big
story and we're gonna talk about Sonic
we're talking about birds of prey we're
gonna give our review of Sonic but this
is what we got to start with because
this is very very important check this
out from cosmic book news birds of prey
fans sabotaging Sonic the Hedgehog this
is this is legit but I'll tell you why
it's very simple
Forbes the success of the new Sonic the
Hedgehog movie shows that Hollywood
needs to listen to gamers boom heavens
because gamers they don't mess around
and look at they have a high quality of
stuff they like to well they're the
customers man exactly
check the story out a birds-of-prey
hashtag is trending with solid reasons
to support Harley Quinn's movie they
changed the name of birds of prey I know
have you ever have you ever seen that
ever happened before
yeah just with that edge of tomorrow but
that's different I know that that's
because people were confused with the
lived I repeat in the center of the ad
and it looked like that was the name of
the movie so so here's what's happening
birds of prey they decided to make a
woke movie yeah basically and they don't
listen to the fans the fans are like yo
hey we here's what we like and they're
like nah we're good we're gonna make a
look movie and then flops mmm
Sonic the Hedgehog there here's why
they're sabotaging it there they're
really really mad because when Sonic
first came out this is what we were
greeted with yay we were greeted with
you ready you that is frightening and
what happened was the fans that's
nightmarish yeah it is it's look at the
teeth what is this yeah I was everybody
was like uh honestly the hands were
creep me out they had to kind of look
like mummified hands to me have you ever
seen a creepy look at and it's almost
like he's wearing gloves he's got
fingernails under his fur yeah what's up
with that is okay okay but anyway here's
what happens right the fans freak out
and they say you've got to change this
and it leads to the movie being pushed
back a major and super expensive over
you hold all of it yeah all of this
guess what happens the movie was great
the movie does really well yeah look at
this over here Sonic has massive Friday
opening of 21 million dollars Wow I
didn't and it was good really good Jim
Carrey is I got I'm gonna say it one of
the best villains yeah I have ever seen
four oh now you mind you this is a kids
movie yeah it's a kids movie but Jim
Carrey I don't know how he pulled it off
but
when I see a villain in a movie yeah
like like when you see Joker and Bette
in the Dark Knight yeah I'm like that's
cool Joker I'm like oh man yeah he's
crazy
yeah not Jim Carrey I was like I'm gonna
punch this guy yeah he was so good at
being insufferable yeah that's true no I
don't I don't know where he learned how
to do this yeah he's no idea he's really
good I realize nobody's he's really
annoying on Twitter that's I love the
first sentence here let me read this
yeah all right so a few fans the few
fans that love it they call them out
right away that there's just a few of
them a few fans of bird of prey that
exist are actually so triggered by the
film's poor performance at the box
office that they're attempting to
sabotage the opening of this weekend's
family-friendly Sonic the Hedgehog movie
it was family Fenris hey Jimmy it's PG
yeah so PG all the things I've been
reading about these people that are so
mad they're saying it was homophobic
there was nothing in it and insane yeah
I was like what what part of the movie
do you I can't now I'm still trying to
think there's not trying to like
literally nothing I'm going through the
movie I'm like where where is no no and
none of the tweets out is looking like
the scene that's like I'm gonna what are
they talking about what spoiler alert
just so I'm a sane a million times but
one of the funniest jokes it's literally
about Olive Garden yeah this is
family-friendly as you get but it was a
really good joke the turtle the turtle
do the turtle Gerald making me so it's
not even a joke it's just shake so in
the beginning in the beginning it's it
actually in the in the yeah yeah and you
saw okay okay you see him running with
the writer and then you see it fly away
it's like oh that's funny so I laughed
again oh god a car almost hits a turtle
but sonic saves the turtle you know
saves it and then he's like man it must
suck being slow all the time and the
next scene is him running filleted this
is your best day ever running of them
and the turtle smiling but nobody said
smile it's just wind yeah then he puts a
turtle down the turtles like shaking it
was good so here's what's crazy they
tried making birds of prey woke Deadpool
yeah it was rated armed but it was like
for kids they made all the woman from be
looking yeah no no no I don't get it and
then like you go into all the stores
like walk through the mall and it's like
skimpy like
in teenager stores like Hot Topic and
they're like all the same outfit that
she's got but like the skimpy version of
it but it's like who's going and
shopping there but it was no adult there
there was like this this thing where
they were claiming that birds of prey
was supposed to like desexualize the
women and not have them be like
objectified or whatever okay at the same
time they both infantilize the women and
made them extremely from be know right
somehow they cross like a grandma and a
toddler like with a really bright color
so but like here's but here's the
paramagnets as it relates to Sonic could
you imagine if they were like people in
movies need to be more realistic that's
like been the big trend with woek movies
yeah like they got mad that Scarlett
Johansson was gonna play a trans man so
the movie got canceled really yeah yeah
she was booked she was booked to star as
a character who was in real life a trans
man but she's female oka so they
cancelled the whole movie because they
don't want actors like people were
people were mad that I think who played
boo played Dumbledore Jude Law was it
Jude Law what's Dumbledore Dumbledore
from Harry Potter oh but they were mad
that he wasn't that they wanted an
actual gay actor okay and so now they're
like women shouldn't be attractive in
movies because they're objectified it's
like dude it's a movie could you imagine
if Jim Carrey playing dr. Robotnik was
just himself
how many kind of was but like yeah he
was he was definitely off the rocker but
have you ever seen the movie the
invention of lying without your vase I
actually hadn't seen it but we had
talked about it and I went and saw it
alright but just I actually did just
recently see that movie so in this movie
they're like no one can lie so movies
are literally people sitting in chairs
reading history right could you imagine
they want no that's what they want so in
Sonic you have Jim Carrey playing dr.
Robotnik and he's insane and as his
crazy handlebar mustache and he's really
really awful and everything he does is
like crazy slapstick Jim Carrey yeah are
we supposed to have him tone it down
because in real life he doesn't act that
way well it's not him being objectified
in that same sexual manner I think
that's what their focus right I'll put
it this way imagine you went to go see
Captain America okay and instead of
Chris Evans they got some like five foot
seven fat dadbod guy and they're like
well not all men look like that Captain
America
oh dude he's a superhero well it's funny
cuz supposed to be crazy first movie
he's this tiny scrawny dude
but that's can't even get into the army
right and turns him into this like
superhuman guy and it's like oh okay
that's what that's like the ideal guy
but right so he's super ripped so should
we nobody complained we complain we
should let's start a campaign I demand
the next Marvel movie have a dude
character was completely out of shape
covered in sweat smells bad you guys
didn't go go over well so like when you
look at see that it's it's not even
about like let's look at this photo
right so look the women you know well
I'm not gonna comment on I don't know
who this lady is is it Rosie Perez in
her name and like a little bit yeah but
like Margot Robbie mary elizabeth
winstead and i don't know this juice
just you smell that sister or something
jurnee smollett jurnee smollett like
they're they're attractive women mm-hmm
but it looks like they tried to not make
them look very attractive because I've
seen photos of all of them looking very
attractive and yet in the background you
have this bust
that's like popping out and she's almost
falling out of her shirt it's kind of
weird so they were just like that maybe
maybe they were just rumors I guess but
I got to say there was a couple scenes
where I was like no even the cop what's
what's the cops I don't yeah Rosen
president okay so even even near the end
of the movie she's popping out because
she's wearing like the corset she's like
oh yeah that course that's the best one
yeah wear that and then she puts it on
and that's all she's wearing it but
there were her busting out so are they
not upset about that they were like
feminists on Twitter saying the reason
birds of prey didn't do well is because
they didn't sexualize the women and all
the young boys didn't want to see women
is like wait wait hold on yes
technically yes
like when I go to sleep no denying that
no no because when I go to see a movie
like I'm not going to a movie to see
real life right I'm going to see
something out of the norm so like super
extraordinary and I'll tell you this I
want my Captain America six-foot tall
and super ripped Chris Evans yeah I
don't want a frumpy fat dude playing
Captain America's Act League and it's
not because I'm sexually attracted to
the man I'm not it's because superheroes
are fit top tier peak humans yeah
exactly and the women don't have to be
like I don't know Hooters girls right
but they look good they look fit toned
they have nice bodies Wonder Woman
is a good examination she's not she's
not overly sexualized they even like
cover it a little bit but she's so even
when she's wearing her trench coat like
investigative gear let's go she looks so
great because it's not about it's not
about making them sex objects it's about
making them look good you know and like
there are things that make women look
good and men look good I mean that
that's not what I was focused on in the
movie what I what bothered me about the
movie was just how overtly
like not realistic it was and not in the
comic-book manner it was just it's like
they never read the comic book at all I
never read a comic that's what it felt
no it's like it's like a dude a male
feminist read a feminist blog and then
made a movie based on what he read yeah
well let's let's get back to Sonic okay
I want to read her so um look there's
not a whole lot to say about the movie
in terms of like a review because what
they're making up but let's get to these
tweets man let's talk about it we can't
[ __ ] we can't show them that's fine but
we can talk about it right right it's
because one of the tweets says one of
the YouTube naughty words okay okay so
we don't we can't bring it up but we
don't know we can say what they said no
no it's easy okay okay let's rate let's
read all right go ahead glad ya know
where we're at here so it says Twitter
user LS mark took screenshots of some of
the tweets noting birds of prey fans
seeing the sonic movie as a threat to
their dumb Harley Quinn will be flopping
at the box office and trying to spread
lies about a sonic movie to make people
not want to see it is the funniest thing
I've seen in a while
it's insane check this out so in these
screenshots and and and there's worse
than this there's like other threads
basically it's a bunch of copy and paste
BOTS yeah exact like or it's just like a
campaign saying homophobic jokes yeah
they're saying dropping you know slur
this one says they have homeless
homophobic slurs through the whole movie
throughout the whole movie absolutely
like sure out the whole movie what we
were sitting there there had to be
probably like 15 kids like the only
adults in yeah well I mean there's
parents all around us with their kids
like I was sitting next to like a 12
year old you know it's just like he was
he was like the whole time like this
movie is so great it was good
yeah it was a good Muslim so so I'll get
see any of that I'll say something
really quick about it the stakes of the
film are not world-ending
I
I prefer like you know grandeur you know
more epic tales but it was Sonic Sonics
personal struggle him fighting a villain
his friend you know him making a friend
yeah there are a bunch of funny jokes in
it very very family-friendly like I
could you know it that the last joke was
seriously good and it was about Olive
Garden because was a product placement
joke that one really I was sitting next
to you definitely left it was great it's
like the last joke and I'm like they
know that they could have done a few
things that would have made the movie
better in my opinion I think the movie
should have started with Robotnik yeah
and it should have started with his
issue and that would have given a better
motivation as to why Sonic was under
threat and why Robotnik was after him
you're totally right they definitely
introduced him little late right oh and
everyone thought so you've seen the
trailer they've already shown this part
so it's not a big spoiler but sonic
there's a sonic boom and then an energy
wave and then the military is like
you're not suggesting who I think you're
suggesting calling Robotnik well we
don't have any other choice but to bring
him in no like yes we do and these Oh
nope we're doing it so this is in the
trailer this isn't the trailer to where
sonic says people are always after my
powers right so that should have been
Robotnik's motivation yeah it only kind
of was right well it it seemed like it
was but you didn't realize it until
after he like I don't I don't respond I
don't know he found out well that's not
really that spoil no that's on the
trailer I found a piece of the quill and
like it's was able to access some of
Sonic's powers and because of that he's
like oh I can I can do this machine that
I've been wanting to build and that's
when there was a slot in the machine
perfectly for a quill well he probably
know he probably designed that but it
should have it's the movie should have
started with Robotnik saying like I
don't have a strong enough power source
for my machines right right and then
after Sonic did the sonic boom he should
have said whatever that was and then
insisted the military let him in right
what I'm pulling here in the movie is
good it was fun at no point was I bored
had no like with birds of prey like I
thought there was a point where thought
of commercials gonna play yeah my Birds
my mind it was embarrassing like I'm I'm
a guy oh I'm a guy I'm I'm
I admit that I'm a guy and so you
confess I confess I'm a man and
throughout that whole movie I was just
like cringing like guys every single guy
I know wouldn't do this wouldn't do this
and now every man was I'm not saying
that it doesn't happen I'm sure it does
in random instances bro I love that
Olive Garden joke the guy he was so well
done and it caught me off guard it did I
heard it I heard it in your giggle I'm
just gonna say it because I'm sure yeah
so just so you know turn it off enough
you don't hear the joke but basically at
the end of the movie the military goes
to give them like a thank you yeah like
handsome an envelope like yeah keeping
everything under wraps because basically
Robotnik was blowing up like monuments
and stuff and killing people he blew up
the pyramid he's with people who have
this thing right right right so he was
like you know this is for keeping
everything quiet we're gonna give you
this and then James Marrs is like what
is it he goes you'll see and he's like
on he opens it it's a gift card to Olive
Garden and he goes the way he said that
I thought it was gonna be something
better I just loved it because he was
like very self-deprecating I'm in the
generals like have you tried their
possible come on something like after
all that but here let's let's read some
more of this birds-of-prey
cosmic book news they say birds of prey
fans are toxic sjw's checking out the
tweets and the toxic birds of prey movie
fans who make up a vocal minute vocal
mint minuscule yeah shows they're
attempting to curb conservative fans and
family's desire to see sonic it's not
conservatives as the conservative
audience was blamed by deadlines for not
supporting birds of prey oh okay simply
because it was female centric know we
went saw it on when did we see on
Thursday we uh we saw opening night
preview night yeah and like all the
season it was crazy
we got good seats we tried to see Sonic
I know probably like there was probably
like 10 people total including all three
of us yeah three of us yeah we tried
seeing Sonic on opening up we couldn't
do it it was it was full yeah so we had
to wait and then we ended up getting
seats off to the side they weren't
really bad and this was I think there
was a Saturday yeah and it was good but
it's I don't even think it's necessarily
fair to try and claim it's all about
conservatives but the but let's get to
the big threat and the reason why
they're doing this it's because the
studio's listen to the fans
and they made money because of it yeah
that is the biggest threat to the
ideology of these weirdos on Twitter
because let me pull up this article hey
birds of prey hashtag is trending with
solid reasons to support Harley Quinn's
movie think about how insane that is
here's how I put it
I love using ice-cream analogies for
business imagine you walked into an
ice-cream shop and you went I'm a big
fan of chocolate ice cream I would like
a scoop please and they went
we don't have chocolate but we do have
broccoli and you are like I'm not going
to buy that
so they started screaming at you and
calling you a bigot and and and you know
you're hateful [ __ ] and then and then
give you a list of reasons why you
should eat that broccoli ice cream even
though it's bad this feels like it kind
of reminds me of that that friend you
have that has that's in a band and that
they're like trying to convince you to
like come see the band and you know they
the oh your friend is a singer but
you've heard them sing they're bad not
good they're not a good singer but you
have to go and they're like no no but
this is you know come come support the
band like it's gonna be good we've been
practicing and you just you heard them
practice like a week before and they're
like still bad but it's another moral
support but then you have all of the
other friends that are going oh man this
is the best band ever they're so good
like you guys could all should all come
see the show and everyone's like we saw
the show last week and it was terrible
like what it see so it reminds me of
Futurama mmm-hmm when they go to the
Amazonian planet oh yeah
yeah they see the they're playing
basketball yeah and they're like this
where female amazonian play basketball
they know Ken dunk but good fundamental
and then fry and Brannigan's art
laughing and laughing and then when they
bring her to the next one they were like
they left at our basketball did you
explain good fundamental they laugh
anyway like they want you to go see
something that is not good yeah the moon
sprays off is not why don't people want
to see it dude people don't like this
stuff yeah people don't like bad movies
but think it's just because it was a bad
movie has nothing to do with any of this
other stuff and you're making up so they
try and scream your sonic now now I'm
the bad guy because I simply think it's
a bad movie it's like No
I'm not but think about trying to help
my fellow moviegoers think about how
crazy don't see it I think about how
crazy the world will be based on how
they view it like you don't go see
movies to be entertained you go for a
moral obligation to support their idea
yeah exactly it's like what does work
yeah dude I don't want to work yeah me
neither I'm going to sit back and laugh
at the blue hedgehog thing spinning
around on the ground and eating chili
talks or whatever it's silly fun I want
to laugh yeah I don't you go here and
you're like I'm doing my good Duty
you're bored how was your time is being
wasted I was I wasn't even really I mean
I have to like half the time I was just
like messing around on my phone and I
was bored I wanted I wanted to pull my
phone but I was like it reminds me about
some other movies too like the last Jedi
I have this meme I'm gonna show you this
meme suppose meme up it's funny screen
so I brought this meme up last time it's
amazing for those that aren't familiar
with Dragon Ball Z there's in the in the
in the Saiyan saga Goku is fighting
Vegeta other two characters and Goku is
worried about collateral damage so he
says let's take this somewhere where
there's less people so the meme it says
let's fight somewhere empty and then
below it there in the theater watching
hurts afraid well they're fighting in
the theater for birds of prey
you know nobody went um I gotta say
though I'm really I am kind of happy you
know why what I'm not I'm not one of
these big you know die-hard fans of like
a particular gaming culture or anything
like that and so I know a lot more fans
are really really they're much more
concerned about this than I am okay like
for me it's like you know you made birds
of prey I don't care but you know what
birds of prey could have been good you
know actually I'm sorry a Harley Quinn
movie would it good right great we're
actually dead naming the movie it's
Harley Quinn Harley Quinn now it's no
birds of prey birds of prey in sebacean
uh whatever I think I think birds of
prey as a comic was feminist II yeah and
that's why they're gonna make it okay
they could have just done Harley Quinn
yeah and it could have been
DC's version of Deadpool yeah I I wish
they did I agree no bird pray like let
her have her own movie but they tried to
squeeze
all this random nonsense into that's why
they change the name like a jarba love
they changed the name from birds of prey
and the fantabulous emancipation of one
harley quinn yeah terrible name they
changed it because fans I mean so
they're kind of doing the same thing -
mm-hmm
like so they changed the name because
fans are like it's not a bird of prey
movie and people were complaining that
they actually Cassandra Cain is supposed
to be mentally disabled right and they
took that away yeah so now people are
like what are you doing you're you're
erase your ableism erasing orders go
listening to the fans
I knew but they're not really fans
that's the thing yeah that's true the
fact they view the movie as more of a
moral duty instead of something to enjoy
shows the real problem yeah could you
imagine like creating a product that's
not to be used for any portrayal purpose
like it I almost imagine like this
imagine uh imagine what the world means
no no but look at this way like when I
buy a wrench
okay I need to you know wrench some I
need to wrench some things when I buy a
screwdriver I need to drive a screw yeah
but imagine there was a company and you
like went to Walmart and it was like a
very important feminist - oh I was like
a weird mishmash bloc and it was like it
does nothing I think I understand that
you're talking about something that is
like to be seen and never ever used it's
like a function list
product decorative pillow Timothy right
like a decorative towel you know
different no because those serve a
purpose if I get a decorative pillow or
a painting or a piece of art that makes
sense it serves a function I'm saying
well add-ins I imagine you walk in a
Walmart and you see an object and you're
like that's gross I don't know what that
is and they say yes but you have to buy
it because the company is feminist you
don't even get a choice okay it does
nothing
it's unappealing it's actually miserable
to look at but it supports feminism ah
you have to put it on your front lawn
that's hard to see it right that's what
this article is reasons to support the
movie what why it's a bad memory I've
never ever seen this before make a good
movie make a good movie and people will
just naturally support it and I think I
think we beat the horse of death and we
can wrap it up by saying yeah sonic
sonic was good success but it was them
listening to the fans yeah and said this
dude his gross fix it and they said okay
so what happened now is one of the
response responses to this whole
narrative like the one that we're
talking about is but it was literally
the same movie the jokes were the same
the writing was the same they just
changed animations and it's like kind of
like the frumpy women in Harley Quinn
could have been made not from be right
can't get right like you did a chance
that you didn't have to overtly
sexualize them that's not what we're
saying but not like have it be more like
the superhero assumes were trapped that
we're we think of in her head like
superhero you envision like like like I
want to say something be a just be a
people you know that are just like out
there you know at the end of the pin
names at the end of the movie huntresses
costume looked like a jumpsuit from from
a thrift store I can't even I can't even
remember that scene I know they're like
all walking together and they're all
kind of wearing similar outfits but I
can't I can't picture it wasn't
memorable to me
so Huntress is wearing a blue jumpsuit
red that jumpsuit and I'm like what what
is this I know yeah it was really weird
yeah like like Katniss Everdeen in in
Hunger Games looked good yeah it was not
objectified no not at all and she's like
a an awesome like woodsman like outfit
it was yeah it was cool yeah it was cool
but not in birds of prey yeah it was
like it was like ha you know what's the
Halloween store called the Halloween
store I think they like pop up every
Halloween example it's like they bought
their costumes from there and I'm not
I'm being serious looked like they were
$10 costume entry so well anyway it's
sonic was great yeah I recommend it
thanks for listening to the fans that's
awesome yes that's pretty cool as that
picture is horrifying with this wee
little teeth in the cash it would've
been a movie they made money I'm excited
for a sequel yeah I can confirm tails is
in the mid credit scene yep that's first
by the og tails voice actress and I'm
stoked I hope they do in the next one so
basically Robotnik ends up in this
mushroom planet right and his moustache
is all big Robotnik he shaves his head
that's great and then it's funny
he's like a normal man would be dead by
now I'll be home by Christiaan by
Christmas yeah it was good Jim Kay was
great
like walking like an idiot right and
then but I really hope they do the Chaos
Emeralds yeah it's gonna have and I want
to see super sonic where he turns goal
and that would be awesome yeah I'm sure
very Dragonball Z like that's gonna be
good rad we'll check it out thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we're live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. and if you want to
catch the full recorded podcast which
doesn't appear in these clips make sure
you join by clicking the button down
below become a member and then go to the
community tab of this YouTube channel
and you can see all of our full episodes
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
if you wanna get more clips like this
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all in the next show
you